hi everyone and thank you for attending
my talk it's my first talk of the PI
data and I'm really happy to be here to
talk about accelerating pi phonetics by
in database processing in other words
i'm going to describe a way that you can
use to speed up your Python analytics by
using database operations and database
and joins so let me first start with a
few words about me I come from France
from Paris I have a master of
engineering from AC Polly and I also
currently a graduate student at the
castle institute of technology in
computer science and I'm mostly
interested in machine learning and cloud
computing and I've been working student
at IBM for more than one year now I'm
based in the lab in the IBM research and
development lab in bubbling in near
stuttgart where I did also my master
thesis and I've been developing Python
tools for in database analytics so I'd
like first to introduce the outline of
this talk we will start with a few
motivation I would just briefly refer to
the Typhon ecosystem for data science
but we will also speak about the
limitation and the solution that you can
have to cope with those then I will
describe how we can bring analytics to
the data and I will introduce IBM dashdb
which is a cloud-based database that we
have at IBM on IBM bluemix and then I
will speak about Python and sequel and
how we can take the advantage of both of
them then I will speak about IBM gb pi
which is the prototype i'm mainly
presenting here it is an open-source
python package and we use it to to speed
up analytics in IBM dashdb using python
and then i will do a demo and hopefully
we have some time for questions and
discussion about it so further
motivation as you all know the python
ecosystem is very rich for performing
that
science and there are a lot of packages
that are used maybe the most famous
could be done by pandas cyclotron for
the machine learning matplotlib for
visualization there are a lot of options
and also you can use I buy a notebook
also personally think there are an
awesome way to form Archie code and to
present inside for example of this
presentation is in a knife in the book
and the problem is that there are a lot
of limitation also with this ecosystem
firstly when you use it in your laptop
or your workstation you are limited by
the speed of your cpu's a number of
cores you have and the amount of RAM and
typically it is very difficult to deal
with data that do not fit in your main
memory so if you have a certain quantity
of RAM in general it's really difficult
to deal with data that do not fit in
your run and another limitation is that
when you do that you need to have the
data locally it has to be in your
computer and this mean has to be
extracted beforehand so you need to take
it from the database put it in your
computers and this is nearly impossible
and especially if you're working on
being quantity of data and also a
solution to do that and I was really
delighted about the keynote of Olivier
today in the morning because he was
speaking about those solution and I'd
like to call it out of course solution
because out of core means that when your
data doesn't fit in the main memory and
we can distinguish between three types
of solution the first one is the first
one is to perform in workstation
computation i would say that for example
at what you can achieve with task and
you have the ability to make data mining
algorithms running in secondary memory
we like hard drive or SSD and then you
kind of alleviate the problem of the
limited amount of RAM but on the other
hand you still have to extract the data
anyway a second way
that I call in cluster computation is
simply to use a cluster so to distribute
the computation on multiple machine in a
network for example Hadoop a spark and
last but not least another solution
which is in database computation and
that's on this this one we are going to
focus on this dog and here the idea is
to bring directly the computation to the
database so we will use the database and
giant to perform computation and this in
so the most efficient way just without
having to extract data and exactly in
database computation has a lot a lot of
advantages and here are a few of them
first database are in general the
backbone of all new teacher
architectures they are just basically
everywhere so why shouldn't we already
use them for performing more than what
you actually do and they have the
advantage of being efficient and
scalable to have they are very good at
storing data retrieving data and they
can typically scale up to big quantity
of data in storage and when you're
performing you an analytics directly in
the database you are you have the
advantage of data freshness that you're
sure that you're actually working on the
most recent version of your data that
your data is not outdated and another
advantage is that you actually avoid
security concerns especially if your
database contains let's say customer
related information such as maybe credit
card numbers or maybe it contains
business critical information then you
don't just don't need to extract it from
the database and you just leave it here
and bring the computation there instead
and so I want just to introduce IBM
dashdb IBM dashdb is a cloud-based data
warehousing system that is available on
our IBM bluemix and it is optimized for
data analytics and data mining it is
based on db2 technology and integrates
blue that is to say it has the ability
to
to have like very efficient data
compression to to reduce the amount of
the quantity of data it can also perform
in memory calm store operation by just
aggregating directly on it and decide if
it can put it in memory or not
automatically and it can scale out up to
a very very big number of nodes as much
as you want using massive parallel
processing and so that's a kind of
situation in which you are after you
have people that want to use the
database for performing analytics so
they will access custom-made sequel
queries and run them and actually I
would like to to ask you I'd like to ask
the audience who can identify to this
situation can you can you show hands if
you're mostly performing analytics
sometimes using just sequel you perform
analytics yeah so a few of them and it
is actually pretty impractical and since
I see that we have so sequel nerds here
I'd like to give you a task and the task
is to compute the mean for each column
given the class in the irish data set so
i assume you all know the iris dataset
and you all know sequel it's actually
pretty easy the secrecy career looks
like this just to select a ridge on the
columns and from eros a new group by so
okay sequel is not that difficult but
still if we compare with by puffin it
would be just only one line so let me
just executed oops yeah and it's just
one line you can do it in one line and
it's it's much much more convenient and
much easier so there is like it looks
like here there is something missing and
you can use something like that Olivier
introduced today in the morning that I
found very interesting blaze the blaze
ecosystem which is in the co system
which provide panda like interface for
multiple backends
and it just basically translates your
Python code into something else like
sequel if it's a database and it has
support for a lot of back end so on the
one side it's an advantage but on the
other side I would say it is
disadvantage because it only supports a
very narrow number of function for each
back in and doesn't have the flexibility
to accommodate two back ends that
provide extra functionality like in
database data mining algorithms and so
we will need something like this a kind
of interface to which we could speak
Python will translate it into a sequel
do the processing is a database and then
retrieve data to map it back into some
Python object like maybe a data frame or
land by Sri something that you know
already and this we like to call it a
sequel push down approach because what
we do is that we translate higher-level
syntax into sequel and then we put them
to the underlying database and as a
user's it has a nice advantage that you
don't have to care about the sequel that
get produced because it was produced
just for you and you never have to touch
sequel and I wanted to show you also
this pull that I found interesting was
done by Katie nuggets and this show you
the top and any tix data mining software
use in 2015 and I wanted to highlight
users to free to 20 source two languages
here you see that almost on the top and
Python and sequel and how I interpret it
personally that I believe people use
Python because they really like the
sleek and very neat syntax it's very
easy to perform multiple queries and
multiple aggregation in any any order
you want but there they are forced to
use sequel because they want to do such
operations on big quantity of data and
typically these are limited by Python so
it looks like there is a need to bridge
the gap between
Python analytics and in database
processing and that's why we introduced
IBM DB pie that's just no persons open
source Python package that provides or
panda like syntax for IBM dashdb IBM db2
also and it is compatible from Python
2.7 up to 3.5 and you can connect with
it using odbc or jdbc so it is basically
cross platform which is I think a nice
advantage and it's gives you a set of
functions for performing data analytics
and database administration at the same
time so this is the big picture
basically what how it works that you
have your users and he has simply Python
installed on his laptop workstation
whatsoever and with a beam gb pipe and
it can issue simple type in commands for
example the first one is for connecting
to the database here I just connect with
database name josh TP and then call the
function called show tables which simply
just return what are the table that are
available in the database and what
happened here that at this point sequel
got generated and pushed to the database
via ODBC JDBC then what is returned back
here is some raw data like a set of
tuples and everything is Matt back in
some data frame object and now I want to
do demo with this tool to show you a
little bit to give you feeling what is
possible with this thing and it's more
I'll say it's more prototype now so it's
it just meant for for fun and for
playing around with the database but it
could be a real robust product I think
so here in the first step I'm going to
I'm connecting to the database for this
we use an object that we call the idea
database there are an abstraction layer
falls for the database and here i
connect to database that is called
dashdb and i already have all the
settings you're not seeing any password
here because I've all the settings in my
odbc sitting and interestingly
activate the variables to true such as
i'm going to show you the sequel
requests i got generated when i do the
next queries and with this type of
object idea database you can perform
database administration so have a look
at what you have what can object models
you have already in the database and in
also i think interestingly you can
upload python data frame to your
database and on the other way around
download some table locally if it's not
too big of course and you can also drop
tables create you you can do everything
you want in python and here the second
step i'm opening a pointer to a table in
my data in my database so here you can
see they are this to a sequel request
got sent up and got pushed down to the
database and this object is now a
pointer to the table so and this is a
law and i think that's an interesting
thing is that you can do non-destructive
what i call non-destructive data
manipulation that is to say you can
virtually modify this data frame by
adding columns at our aggregation of
auto columns etc but actually without
are tearing at all the table so you can
also perform on the top of that
statistics filtering sorting and in the
future that will be of course many more
function i believe and does everything
in the panda like syntax so i'm going to
give you a first example which is I
think the easiest yeah as you just see
here I actually I didn't explain but I
opened a pointer to the iris data frame
which is already loaded in iris table
which is already loaded in my database
so here I'm going to ask for the head of
iris and okay so you can just see it
just return me the first record of the
table it was just kind of very basic
things you can do but I think there are
more interesting things for example the
computation of the correlation matrix
this kind of things that can be very
computationally expensive and so you can
see what
executing this very small line of code
I'm able to retrieve the correlation
matrix just as I would do with Python
but instead I didn't have to write all
those things maybe I should put it
higher what's your emergency and I think
this one is also interesting because
it's performing a various aggregation on
each column and this is typically here
interesting to see how much sequel get
generated for us that we didn't have to
write and in the end we have the result
so I think kind of interesting things
because in this case the table is very
small of course the iris dataset it has
only 150 row and but it could be
arbitrary big and you can do some bit
more advanced things like feature
engineering data manipulation i would
say here for example i just select three
columns here i create a column that I
call new and which will be the addition
of one column plus the mean of another
column and so okay it's just done and
now I can visualize a result if I want
we head for example and here you can see
here we have the results of this new
column was created by doing the sum of
the sepal length plus a mean accessible
with and you can see here if you if it's
not too small you can see the
corresponding sequel request support
length plus this I guess it's a mean of
the support with actually yeah i'm yeah
that's exactly the thing i'm working
directly on the data and that was
exactly the point of this slide is you
you can see for example let's say i call
iris i just have the object it's a
pointer the data is not in my local
computer i would say however i can call
the print function that I think it
interesting just returned me a sequel
request that correspond to the view that
I have of the table i'm currently
manipulating
so for a sequel nerds it's interesting
and you can do more than that especially
because we have other things that are
available in the database such as
machine learning algorithms that are
able to run directly in the database and
what we want to do is that we want to
provide wrappers for them so that you
can use them and so I said there is into
the base algorithms and for example now
with IBM deep I you can use you can run
k-means an eighth base Association rules
but there are more already in the
database and we don't we will provide
the wrapper in the future there's for
example linear regression there is
decision trees so you can do all those
things and the idea is to map them in a
psychic learn like syntax because people
are used to this syntax so here I'm just
calling from the IBM deep I learned
supermodel k-means and i initialize the
k-means k-means clustering with flea
free clusters and okay I'm just
reopening my database my pointer to the
data frame 0 to the table so I reopened
my idea that the frame and now i'm going
to do like if I was with scikit-learn
I'm going to fit and predict on the iris
dataset and as you can see here we are
calling a specific in database function
which is called idx k-means and it just
passed all the parameter force we don't
have to care about it and now we're
calling the predicted k-means and here
is a result so you can see that for each
line we have a prediction that has been
a not a prediction but because it's a
inceput it's unsupervised learning but a
cluster that has been assigned for
examples for the line number one we add
a cluster it's a sign to cluster ID 1
and it is at this distance zero point
the data data pointed at this distance
and etc so we can do directly data
mining ago isn't without having to
download anything or to use a cluster
and here yeah it's just the following of
the k-means clustering i can return the
description of
cluster so we just found three clusters
and with those means and yeah that I
think pretty much interesting and I
wanted to give you a sneak preview about
what I've been doing more recently I've
been as I said doing my master thesis at
IBM also and our work I've been working
on an extension of IBM DB pie where I
enable in database feature selection
that is to say I try to enable the
estimation of the interest in aunty
quality of features for doing a
prediction and there are many ways to do
that one of the ways for example to
compute the information gain I don't
know if I want to explain that now but
yeah information gain is also called
mutual information and just the quantity
that tells you the amount of information
that is shared by two variables and we
can use that to get an estimation of how
interesting is an attribute for
predicting another one so I'm just
opening again iris dataset and I'm
calling my FOP n function and here you
can see those all the sequel that get
generated and in the end I have an
information gain matrix that is returned
I put missing value on the diagonals
because it's not interesting to predict
the information gained offer variable
with itself will be necessarily maximal
so here basically you can see all the
sequel things sequel requests were just
generated to compute values entropy
measure that we used to do too we use to
compute the information gained and now I
want to give you just a small
performance conversion of how would have
been if i wanted to do those kind of
thing directly in this computer in my
logbook and if i was doing it on the
other side with IBM dashdb and three
plan on blooming so that's typically
what you you can get for free on IBM
bluemix and so just a speck of my
computer it has just entered
core 52.6 ecards and 16 gigabyte ram so
it's just a standard with a standard
configuration and here's a plot for the
covariance matrix so just competing the
covariance matrix here is a number of
roles so what we do is that we take the
same data frame same table and we make
it scale and here's the number of
seconds the queries took two to
execution to compute the metrics even
blue you have in database run time and
in red you have in memory runtime and
Terry it's a bit small why I say it and
so you can see that the in database run
time running scales much better than the
in-memory runtime and this is what
actually we take we measured on is a
pure computation not we didn't take into
account the time needed to download the
data at first also and it would be much
much bigger otherwise also when you use
panda when you open it data frame it
depending on the size of that frame it
can take a long time to and I think a
point that is particularly interesting
here is this point here because you can
see that from this point the in database
run time becomes more interesting that
the in-memory run time and it's about
actually here it's about half a million
rolls so when you have their frame that
is bigger than half a million rows it's
more interesting to use in database run
times and in memory but if you're
working in very small data and it's
better to do it locally mmm I don't know
why oh you know it was I wanted to show
another plot oh yeah there is another
plot after okay
and this plot is for the pivot table
function if you don't know it is just a
function in pandas that compute some
aggregation based on on the value of the
columns and here we just count the
occurrence for each class and so you can
see that here again the in database run
time does get better but I think the
most interesting here is this point and
what happened here actually is that I
had a out of core I mean out of memory
error in my laptop and that means that
from this point which is a data frame
that had 18 nking million rolls I wasn't
able to process it anywhere anyway in my
local computer so I I just put it this
plot because I find it funny that it was
it was not possible anymore to do the
experiment and for the deployment of
this this Python package it is already
available on pi PI so you can give it a
try if you want people install identify
and we have it on get up and it is under
the bsd license under the IBM DB NIT
groups and for future work as i said is
really a prototype for now what we want
to provide is that we want to provide a
full test coverage we already have a
basic test coverage but we cannot
guarantee the absence of bugs of course
and there will be more features coming
soon such as the ability to compute
things from different tables because one
of the typical use case of the typical
schemas that are using a database and
data warehouses is that a star shima so
you have your data that is pleated
around various tables and you need to
join them or merge them before so that
we want to enable it with IBM GE pi
maybe what would be interesting is to
have some function for retrieving
samples of the data in a in a clever way
maybe certifies and pull something like
this and we want to provide more machine
learning wrappers as I said there are
more algorithms are already available
and we will integrate soon
work have i've been doing in feature
selection and i have a few colleagues
working on in database ukyo special
analytics so now i'm going to go for the
conclusion IBM DB pie is an interface
for in database computing and it relies
on just on the database and shine so
what is i think here interesting that
tree doesn't matter how powerful is your
workstation or computer i could do that
with a very minimal very simple hardware
like maybe a raspberry pie or something
even smaller and you don't need to
extract the data at all so you sure
you're working on the most recent
version of the data and you avoid
security concern but by not spreading
your data out of your database and it is
intuitive because we use we mimic i
would say we mimic the Panda and the
psychic learn syntax and it showed great
performance on big move it's a big
enough data sets however there are a few
drawbacks of course like if you are
connecting to a remote instance a
database instance then if it's not in
your local network you need to go
through the internet so you cannot you
cannot do if you are offline and it is
working only for IBM dashdb IBM db2
because of course it's it's a rapper
that called specific function from IBM
db2 IBM dashdb and it covers off course
only a small part of Python analytics
capabilities because there are so many
things you can do with psychic learn or
panda we couldn't anyway cover
everything and yeah if there are our
users here just want to say that we have
a similar interface for our which is
called IBM gbr so maybe you want to
check this out and that's it for me i
want to thank you for your attention and
i will be very happy to answer your
question if you have some
thank you very much I think it was a
very good mix of practice and the theory
although Sprague I really like those
excuse me if I i missed that just the
first performance chart that you showed
yeah of course I'm just wondering why
did you have these pics and debs that's
a very good question and actually I
wanted to say during the thought that I
didn't know and I'd liked somebody to
explain me because I noticed that at the
beginning and then I told myself okay so
it's normal just like I'm performing a
second experiment for each data point
but the truth is that here I'm
performing several experiment for each
point actually I'm performing free and I
do the rate of it so maybe it's not
enough for getting rid of the variance
may be there are another reason i don't
know maybe if somebody can answer this
question why panda has such or is it me
or wipe on that has such a variance I
also asking myself so good that you
pointed out it is on the covariance
matrix function so I don't know how it's
the implementation of the covariance
matrix function but who'd be interesting
to see maybe depending on the size of
the table they are different address
assignment in the background or I don't
know yes isiliye this is the question
that I would like to to make sure you're
not right now where are you oh yeah hey
well have you run this a this benchmark
would we'd say you compare the two
little different things of running
Python analytics in database and not
have you run thought in a variety of
different data sets Oh on that on
different data sets you mean a different
machine learning tasks yeah well it
depends here we just focus
I did other analyzes and just the
covariance matrix I did others here are
just selected a sample I we could use
all their data sets here actually I'm
using a data set that he'll 12 columns
it is Titanic data set that maybe you
will you know maybe from Cagle that you
can download it I assume also depending
on of course it depends on the size the
number of columns here we have only this
capability with the number of rows we
didn't plot the scalability with the
number of columns but would be also
interesting to see but yeah I I tried
all the plots but those where I think
the most interesting one yes I'm the
second part and have you taken account
all these all these different things
that one has to take to have in mind in
order to produce an appropriate
interface on a database I mean that
having only interface for it since you
are working with a data you wrote more
the data you need to keep the database
here the after that operation keep it
Elfi you mean keep it here not
distracted yeah exactly that's the idea
of the thing to do non-destructive
manipulation and we basically never
write anything we do only almost only
select queries we return results but we
don't write in the table but we do we do
do some some things like maybe you you
could see it we are creating views but
they got here for example here you can
see I create some view here but we
automatically always drop them after
without just temporary view so we have
to exactly that's a big problem actually
that you're speaking and you're more
than welcome to talk to it well there is
a go yeah you can turn next other people
can speak her offline if you want I
would be very happy about that I have a
question on maybe on the database size
side the do you have the ability to
upload
user-defined functions and user-defined
aggregate functions that you would write
in Python our CEO or something else we
that's a very good question we could do
it maybe we will do it in the future for
now we're not doing it we only
performing a range of sequel queries but
we could also imagine defining user
defined functions I think that's very
that's at some point I asked me as I
asked myself this question or sofa I had
to do that but for the integrity of the
database we wanted to not creating
functions and this database exactly in
the state it was at the beginning so
maybe we could think about how to delete
them after we use them but then that's a
question when if the people just shut
down the terminal how could we clean
that but that's a very interesting point
and so you said that this is a special
for IBM dashdb but so to my like I aya
this seems like normal SQL so can you
support also other backgrounds yeah
actually it's possible IBM dashdb an IBM
db2 as a have a different dialect of SQL
actually but it's very close to normal
in school so what could happen and that
stuff would be totally ok that you can
fork the code and you can just change a
little bit the queries and then it would
work for all the backends all the sequel
beckons but of course for example things
that you couldn't port would be for
example came in clustering would be very
difficult to port because you would need
to have also in database clustering and
database k-means but otherwise it's very
actually very easy to port I think most
of the thing you can put them
I just want to ask in the similar
direction if you have a say post class
or or or whatever database then the only
thing to do is to adopt the code to
quote to have regular SQL and to have
the right driver right exactly yeah you
have just two you can fork as a project
change the sequel queries and then of
course you have let me show us a bigger
picture I have it at the end here that
could this could be here something you
have to adapt to to connect with ODBC
JDBC we support both with IBM GFI and of
course you need to have the db2 driver
and would be the same for others yeah
but basically every just the only things
you need to change so related questions
at the beginning of the presentation you
said that it's related to blaze but
blaze is more a general it's possible
gotta be and whatever there is also i
beez which is more recent and this is
very focused on sequel so it's very
similar to your project how does it
compare if you would stop today with you
use ibis instead or that's a very
interesting question actually the
eyepiece project started two months
after i started this project and it is
working only for impala and yeah yeah
yeah exactly postgres impala and it is i
think it's interesting and there should
be some possibility to share some code
on that but yeah I heard about it and
it's kind of exactly a solution to the
fact that place is too general for
platforms that provide enhanced
functions like data mining algorithms
but it's a I would say it's kind of the
same but for another back end um thank
you very much a dork for this very
interesting talk
you